what's more impressive than a Jedi two
Jedi but there's one reason where soca's
powerful dyad it doesn't make all that
much sense most of the titles in Ahsoka
offer a pretty clear insight into each
episode's themes master and Apprentice
features the uncomfortable reunion of
Ahsoka Tano and aparawan Sabine ran Toil
and Trouble features plenty of both and
acts as a Nifty reference to the witchy
ways of Morgan ellsbeth time to fly
gives us a cool space battle and a pot
of space-faring burgail while Fallen
Jedi deals with the aftermath of
ahsoka's defeat to Balin scar Shadow
Warrior features Anakin's return in the
world Between Worlds and Far Far Away
takes us into an entirely new Galaxy you
get the drill part 7 dreams and Madness
takes things in a more esoteric
Direction the episode does feature
plenty of both from baylen's wish to
find the hidden power and paridia to
thrawn's meddling with the knight's
sister's magic however the events don't
fit the title quite as snuggly as fans
of the show might be used to which makes
dreams of Madness the perfect episode to
whip out a particularly strange Force
Power early in the episode Ahsoka
locates a beam by using the force to
reach out to her with the action scenes
and plot developments that follow it's
easy to chalk this up as a kind of
everyday for shenanigans a Jedi are
known for however this being Star Wars
every single application of the force
has an extremely detailed history this
particular power move is known as the
force diet and is essentially a bond
between two Force sensitive individuals
the most famous sciatic Connection in
the Star Wars franchise is a fraud yet
passionate dynamic between kylo Ren and
Rey around which most the sequel Trilogy
revolves notably though both kylo and
Rey have already proven themselves as
powerful force users by the time their
diet establishes itself here's the
problem though because it's been
explicitly stated that sabine's
connection to the force is at the lower
end of the scale as far as Jedi
apprentices go it should be utterly
impossible for Ahsoka to forge such a
connection with her well I just
worst candidate
candidate Jedi he's ever ever known
ahsoka's Ironclad connection with the
force has been firmly established over
the course of her many many appearances
in the Star Wars franchise in Ahsoka
she's not only a masterful combatant but
so powerful that she can handily use
rare Force powers like psychometry
because of this it's entirely believable
that she might be able to maintain a
forced dire connection to another person
however the dyadic connection
historically requires both sides to be
totally in tune with the force which has
been very much isn't what a Socrates
have been clearly share a strong if
sometimes strange relationship Ahsoka
has spent plenty of time hammering home
the apparent fact that Sabine is all but
useless in the ways of the force as
surges should be quite impossible for
Ahsoka to maintain a force bond with her
Padawan of course thus assuming that
sabine's Force sensitivity is at the
virtually non-existent level the series
has shown so far despite the show's
insistence that Sabine is a low end
Force user at best Ahsoka has
essentially telegraphed the end of her
Arc by including several scenes that
tease her successful use of force powers
at this point a scene where she finally
learns to wiggle the force is virtually
guaranteed with that in mind the fact
that Ahsoka is able to locate her with
her apparent use of a force diad seems
like a subtle hint that Sabine is far
more powerful than she realizes no doubt
it will be fascinating to see where
Ahsoka takes her as the series reaches
its conclusion
foreign